bill burr upset people at the grammys
they said
and i saw what he said and he didn't he
didn't really upset anyone
he didn't really even say much really um
and you know what i started to realize
what's going on a lot in the news these
days is a reverse
uh psychology
basically
you know billboard didn't really say
anything
but suddenly there's an uproar and then
it becomes a thing but the uproar is
just created because
uh that way people go see the clip right
we know that kind of stuff
people go see the club whether it
happened or not
but then i started to think like as some
bigger stuff you know i started to think
about
um the dr seuss thing
and here's my theory on dr seuss
for one i started to think that
i bet i bet someone had a lot of dr
seuss books
that the sales on them had probably
slowed down
because i don't know if people are
buying as dr seuss as much
you ask kid these days if who dr seuss
is they think it's an actual doctor they
think it's an indian guy
let's be honest so
um i think the big deal is
somebody i bet probably had too many
doctors whose books they couldn't sell
them company whatever
so they said well let's let's create
this blurb let's create this hubbub
let's make it so that oh these these
books are going to get discontinued
let's influence whoever we can to get
these books discontinued or banned or
whatever
so then suddenly everyone goes and buys
the dr seuss books
now everybody's cat in the head it up
everybody's hammed and greened
you know and everybody's [ __ ] hearing
horton's in the distance you know it is
what it is
but now they've sold more books than
ever just because so people can be like
why you know
so the whole thing is just a trick
really
whoever's discontinued the books they
don't really care
in the end they're just trying to sell
some books
i think the same thing was true with the
mr potato head they said oh mr potato
they're just trying to sell [ __ ]
plastic vegetables bro
that's it no one re it's all a trick
once they have us clicking on whatever
boom
then we've already then our time our
attention you know once you give your
attention to something that's it
because that's your value is your
attention
um so anyway yeah billboard didn't say
anything
and if you looked at the clip he didn't
say anything oh some cis white male i
didn't give
it seemed ridiculous the the category
they haven't given him but it just
whatever you know
i like it he went out it was just kind
of him in the brief moment he could be
there wasn't a ton of opportunity for
him
uh to really emphasize his personality
but you know but yeah it's all a trick
man
then you got that now you got the book
and now you're st you're standing your
ground
but it's just getting weirder
they you know you're tearing down the
statue chair i'm just trying to get rid
of history i just don't understand why
you just don't leave history where it is
it's already gone hope you enjoyed that
video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one